[Music]
joining me this week is an author a
columnist and a fellow at The irand
Institute Don Watkins welcome to the
Ruben report good to be here irand you
say the name irand people go completely
bananas MH why is that well I mean she
challenges basically most of the ideas
that people hold dear I mean for people
on the left of course she's for
capitalism for people who are quot on
the right she's against religion and for
everybody she's challenging the idea
that self-sacrifice is the essence of
morality so I mean it's easy to make
enemies if you have those sorts of views
yeah so the objectivist or you know what
I before I even uh preface this with any
of my thoughts on objectivism tell me
what objectivism is so objectivism is a
philosophy and I mean you can think of a
philosophy as your basic framework for
Integra ating your knowledge and your
action and so the idea is that like we
have to make sense of the world that
we're living in and trying to govern
ourselves through like what should I be
trying to achieve in my life how am I
going to try to achieve it and then how
can I gain knowledge in order to do it
and that's what a philosophy is giving
you and we all have kind of like
implicit answers to that right we all
have sort of our kind of attitudes about
you know the kind of person what do you
regard as important in life what are you
going to take as a as a a convincing
argument what uh is your basic view of
human nature are we driven by kind of
desires and emotions are we beings who
can govern ourselves by reason like
these are questions that people we can't
escape having a view on even to like get
out of bed and go to work but the
question that you face then is are you
going to really try to arrive at a view
rationally methodically that you can
logically justify and that is coherent
or are you just going to let this kind
of grab bag that you've assembled over
the course of your life guide you which
really means are you going to be out of
control and so her particular take on
philosophy I mean the way she boiled it
down is that she stood for reason uh
self-interest rational self-interest and
less air capitalism um but the way I
like to think about it is more that the
real essence of it is living a life
rationally and productively and then
what are the requirements for that
politically and then what are the
assumptions underlying that at a at a
metaphysical level in terms of what kind
of world we live in but the real core of
her vision is that like make something
in your life go out there be creative
create something beautiful and do it by
using reason and I think that's just
such an empowering framework I've had
the co-author of your book youron Brooke
on this show and even when I just said I
was going to have him on the show the
reaction that people oh IR ran you know
it's selfish and evil and capitalism and
all that stuff so a lot of I assume a
lot of your your work just has to be
extricating yourself from people's
preconceived notions right yeah there's
definitely a lot of that but I I mean I
actually find it as an advantage and
empowering I think most what people do
that on the surface seems like it's
intended to be persuasive is not
actually intended to be persuasive
people can appeal to existing tribes
right I'm going to appeal to the
conservative tribe and then I'm going to
become successful by you know taking the
best pot shots or I'm going to appeal to
my liberal tribe when you have a view
that's very outside the mainstream and
if you want to not just talk to your
five friends in a closet now thankfully
there's more irran supporters than five
but when you're that outside the
mainstream you have to think really
deeply like what do other people believe
what are their best Arguments for it can
I really answer those arguments and so I
think it it really motivates you uh I
don't find it demotivating I find it
kind of like a challenge to rise to how
can I really think about what why is it
that people disagree with these views
and then how can I overcome it given
that like I really see that these views
are true they do help you understand the
World and Achieve happiness in your life
yeah what do you do as a fellow to The
irran Institute what does a fellow
actually do yeah I mean it's kind of a
really odd title like oh so you're a
nice fellow yeah you're a fell I mean
the way I think about it is that I get
paid to have opinions and then tell
people about them um but it it really is
it's taking a philosophic framework and
using it to illuminate the issues that
are most vital to understanding human
life and in in particular my focus is on
business and part of that is the
political side of it what are the
requirements for people to be able to
produce the material wealth that all our
lives depend on um and then but at a
deeper level it's my my the essence of
my career is really about Justice for
producers so it's that these are people
people who create the values whether
it's businessmen who create the material
values whether it's scientists who
discover the fundamental knowledge that
guides Our Lives whether it's artists
who create enormous spiritual values um
I think particularly towards businessmen
there's been this real persecution and I
regard it as a terrible Injustice and so
I view a lot of what my work is about as
driven by the idea of here's good people
being persecuted in a really unjust way
and most people regard that as right and
I Ed as really really wrong yeah what do
you think that's about this sort of need
I mean you see this in the mainstream
all the time we constantly demonize
business we demonize Wall Street now I
would argue Wall Street has done plenty
of things wrong and you know uh we
shouldn't have just unfettered complete
craziness that they often give us but
what do you think that constant
demonization of business is really about
I mean I think it occurs on a number of
different levels but I think one of the
most alarming reasons that it occurs is
that einan had this point that anybody
who wants power needs a scapegoat you
need somebody who can take the blame for
the sins and then you give them power to
fight that villain and I mean you can
see this in the rise of any dictatorship
but it happens it happens even in a
country like ours that is still
predominantly or in many ways free it's
that people who want power and people
want to push their agenda yeah exactly
they need scapegoats and businessmen
make a perfect scapegoat precisely
because if we've been taught that the
essence of morality is
selflessness well whatever you can say
about a Steve Jobs or Bill Gates they're
certainly not selfless I mean they're
making lots of money they're doing what
they love they're putting out products
that they think are going to outdo the
competition so we conclude well they're
selfish well what have we been taught
about selfishness well it's that it is
trampling over people it's sacrificing
over people we have no category of the
producer the producer the person who
creat creates for his own benefit for
his own joy and for furthering his own
goals but isn't trampling over others
and isn't selflessly sacrificing himself
and so what happens because we don't
have the category of producer who else
do we put in the categor of selfish we
put Steve Jobs we put Bill Gates well we
also rightfully I mean we also put a
Bernie maid off you know an Al Capone
the people who are slitting other
people's throats picking their pockets
and destroying their lives m so we
subtly equate those two and one of the
ways that this works out in practice is
that then when we see a a businessman
who turns out to be a fraud say you know
somebody like made off on Wall Street we
don't conclude the way that we would if
a teacher committed a crime oh there's a
person who was a criminal and had a
certain kind of job we say this is proof
that all businessmen are corrupt and you
can it it makes sense because we view
the profit mod motive in effect we say
look there's a certain kind of motive I
want more more more for me and I don't
care how I get it some people get it by
selling products other people get it by
picking each other's Pockets some people
get it you know through pillage and and
total Destruction but it's all on the
same Spectrum it's all the same drive
it's all the same desires that are
animating these people and part of what
I think if you actually think about it
deeply that is not true at all Steve
Jobs's motivation for creating beautiful
products in a great company that has
nothing to do with the motivation of a
Bernie moff who was trying to prove that
he was a big shot and you know prove
that he was a great intelligent investor
um rather than actually enjoying being a
real investor and and so you need to
separate those two motives and we don't
yeah what what do you make of the idea
that we also sort of Li we demonize some
of these people and then we we lionize
some of them like Steve Jobs for example
I mean apple right now they still
Outsource a ton of their work but people
on the left have no problem with that
right I mean that doesn't seem to be a
problem everyone thinks Apple's so great
they're made in copertino or you know
what do they say designed in copertino
and made in China well yeah but notice
that they actually have taken a lot of
heat there was a whole slew of stories
about the state of the factories in
China never mind that people came to
those factories because they were way
better than the Farms that they
basically were living in poverty on but
that that always seems to get lost in
this that these people actually do want
these jobs yeah in fact I mean we cite
in the book a researcher who went there
and spend time with the women in these
factories predominantly women and they
were not complaining about conditions
that you or I would find deplorable
because like you always judge things by
your best option available and if your
next best option available is to
basically live on a farm where you have
zero opportunity then this is a step in
the right direction now I think we
should want it to be better and the way
that it gets better is more freedom in
China and freedom to immigrate to a
place like the United States it doesn't
get better by just destroying an
opportunity but if but if we're talking
about the view of Steve Jobs in many
ways he's the exception that proves the
rule because he's so clearly perceived
or was perceived as an artist more than
a businessman and it was when he was
seen as a businessman making
business-oriented decisions say for
instance the how much they were going to
charge for the original iPhone well he
took the same heat as the rest of them
the book deal uh that you know he got
slapped down with antitrust now that
mostly played out after his death but
nevertheless to the extent that people
saw him as a businessman he he tended to
fall into the same bucket that's
interesting so we like the innovator the
person that was coming up with the ideas
but the same guy who was you know
leading the business practices once that
sort of came to light then that that
hurt his image so that's right and the
but in fact it's part of the same motive
that these are people who love to build
things and if you if you think like what
is the meaning of life I think part of
einan's answer a way to think think
about her answer it's it's that that
feeling of craftsmanship when you're
doing something that you regard as true
and important and good and that kind of
experience you have when you're just
focused on it embeding it and building
something amazing like that is the
meaning of life because that's how you
support your own life that's how you
achieve your own goals and just the
experience of that is so empowering and
good that like if that's your view of
what it means to be selfish first of all
you'll never put a swindler made off in
that category and second of all it's
really how hard to see how that is bad
it's very hard to see that that is
something negative for human life when
really it's really the essence of what
gets us out of bed in the morning is
that the best argument for small
government that there is because nobody
that's working for government wakes up
and thinks that they own this and can by
working harder you know you're like
you're sort of dulled into yeah you'll
rise up and you'll get these raises and
all those things but you don't own it
it's not yours versus someone that goes
out there and starts a small business
and will have all the success and all
the failures that come with that but
that's what life's all about I mean the
best the best argument is what's
required for all of us to be able to
make and build the kind of life that we
want to live and I think that if you
really think deeply about the kind of
life you should want to live a virtuous
life it should be centered around
productiveness it should be centered
around creating things that you regard
as important and beautiful
um but the the only way that you can
have that and have it on a massive scale
and then have innovators arise who don't
just do it but do it at a at a level
that changes the way that we live in
work the only way you do that is if you
have a society where I cannot stop you
from living the kind of life that you
want from acting on your judgment acting
on your own independent initiative
because look we don't need the
government to protect people doing
popular things we don't need the
government to protect people who are
doing things that everybody approves of
or advocating ideas that everybody
agrees with we need the government
precisely to protect the the The
Outsider the minority the innovator and
the only way you can do that is if you
really stand for rights on principle the
idea that the only purpose of government
is to protect the freedom of the
individual to to make his own choices
and pursue his own happiness and that's
really the kind of connection that iron
has a view of what the moral life is and
her view is you can't force people to do
that you can't force people to be
creative to be rational but you can
protect everybody's freedom to make the
choice to be creative and rational what
argument do you hear the most pushing
back on these ideas what's what's the
thing that you hear um I mean there
whether you agree with it or not I
suspect you you don't but you know what
do you hear usually if you're you're out
there and you're pushing these ideas
well I mean if you mean on a political
level I think you know certainly the
inequality camp cign and the idea that
look what you're talking about is a do
eat dog one where the rich and Powerful
get more rich and powerful and take
advantage of everybody else I mean it's
that whole idea it's the idea that that
you're just unleashing selfishness sort
of you're unleashing selfishness but it
also it'll often be put in terms of
power it's the idea that what you're
doing is you are crafting a system
that's made for the powerful that's made
for the the you know the able at the
expens of the week and and so I think
that sort of objection
is it really is the most common one it
has so many iterations it comes up in
every sort of debate you can think of
the minimum wage debate oh it's you're
privileging the rich against the poor
it's you don't care about the poor I
mean it comes up in the debate um over I
mean it in basically every sort of
debate you can think of it
um whether it's you know should we have
Dodd Frank are we going to you you know
allow the big powerful Banks to control
us are we going to re them in for the
sake of everyone um that sort of
perspective I think is now it is related
to the idea of selfishness because it's
you know it's the powerful people driven
by their selfish urges rather than the
public good so what we need to do is
give enormous political power to people
like you know Paul Krugman and people
like Barack Obama who allegedly you know
are out for the public good instead of
their own self-interest um but you're
saying they might actually be out for
their self-interest well no it's I mean
what they're out for is um they're not
out for their rational self-interest so
I think power lust you know you can say
it's let me put it
differently selfishness in Ein ran
conception is not a motive it's it's not
like an emotion or a drive it's a goal
it's a it's a moral standard that you
should use to select your actions so for
instance let's take a kind of subset it
which is Health um would you say
everybody's pursuing their health well
no clearly we can see people who don't
think about their health at all and
there's certain people who do think
about it and say you know what I'm a
foodie to me it's much more important to
just get you know the best food I'm
going to have and that's what it means
in life and if I gain a little weight
and if I die five years sooner who the
heck wants to live if you don't get to
eat you know a bunch of cupcakes
throughout your life right um so but
selfishness in her view is a kind of
gold but if you take it seriously as a
goal you have to think about the means
for it you and you can't get to that
goal doing whatever you feel like any
more than you can get to health doing
whatever you feel like doing so it's
something that has to be thought of
scientifically and the science that that
answers the question what does your
interest genuinely consist of that is
the job of morality and so I mean that
to me is what if you're going to ask at
the end of the day what matters to me
it's that question of how do you live a
virtuous life and the reason that you
should be concerned with living a
virtuous life is because your happiness
in life depends on it right so we
usually don't think of these things
traditionally in the same sentence sort
of selfishly living and how that can be
virtuous but I think you would argue
that if you were truly living a selfish
life for yourself the right way you
would self-regulate right like you would
do the things that wouldn't you wouldn't
pollute the lake in your neighborhood
just so you can make more money because
you know that you like that lake or your
neighbors like that lake or you like to
go swimming every now and again that
there's a self-regulating in it that I
that comes from the self and not from
the government is that is that fair to
say yeah I mean think about it this way
like you have kids and you have to give
them advice on how to live their lives
and you want the best for them you want
them to be happy fulfilled have meaning
in their lives is your advice going to
be do whatever you feel like doing is
your advice going to be be like Bernie
maid off like no that we have a sense
that that is is not selfish what we need
is a rigorous understanding that deeply
analyzes what is our self-interest
consist of now you threw out the
contrast of like polluting your L for
money and I think look money is really
important but that is so far from being
the essence of life and the essence of
your self-interest that to equate those
two as the critics of self-interest do
is really insane I mean when you think
about the kind of joy and meaning that
comes from creating amazing things
experiencing profound art and having
really deep relationships with people
whom you admire and share values about
like that is the core of a selfish life
and now certainly einan I think is is uh
rare to hold a view like that but she's
not alone you know we typically equate
morality with selflessness but um
historically I mean if you go back to
the Greeks they had a very similar
conception that morality was supposed to
be practical it was supposed to give you
real guidance on on how to live the best
life and I think they got a number of
things wrong but the core of what they
did get right or at least certainly
Aristotle got like right is that a a
life directed at your own interest and
your own happiness is a life of reason
and so one way to think about what Ein
ran is saying is set aside the issue of
selfishness versus selflessness focus on
the issue of what's good for you what's
good for you is live a life of Reason
which means that like you do everything
in your power to understand the world so
you can govern yourself through it you
know don't go by emotions emotions are a
great thing to consume in like they're
they're not how you produce the great
values of your life but that's the
reward that's the consumption of your
life is is great emotions like that
whole focus is really I think what
interests her yeah so what's the
difference between a pure objectivist
and just a Libertarian for as much as we
can Define what a Libertarian is well I
think that's part of the problem is it's
a really vague term um I would say at
one level the easiest level to get the
difference and probably the least
controversial one the one that even
Libertarians would agree that there's a
big difference between them and
objectivism is that they're a political
ideology at best um it it's it's telling
you how should you structure a a society
what's the role of government and you
know what should be the the sort of
Institutions and principles regulating
laws and so on um and objectivism has a
view on those issues it has as a as a
philosophy it has a politics but it is a
philosophy it's giving you guidance
about how to think and how to live and
politics is in effect the kind of least
important branch in the sense that like
the real cash value philosophy is are
you happy is your life better than
before you had it and or if you had the
wrong philosophy and so libert arianism
at the minimum difference is simply that
it doesn't it doesn't comment on deeper
philosophic issues now libertarianism as
an ideology that arose really during the
70s and was pioneered by Murray rothbard
which is a more delimited subset of the
people who call them Libertarians now
they were anti- idology they they
basically said libertarianism means that
is can be defended on any philosophic
basis so we don't care whether you're a
a you know social justice Warrior
egalitarian who wants to cut down the
successful we don't care whether you're
a fundamentalist Islamic totalitarian
freedom is great for everybody it helps
everybody achieve their goals and so it
was rabidly anti- ideology right um I
don't think all Libertarians hold that
you know you talk about being a
classical liberal and I think that's a
much healthier kind of orientation
because if you look at the classical
liberals they were interested in
political views but from a certain
philosophic perspective now they
disagreed in a lot but what you can say
is at minimum they saw themselves as
being pro- reason because it I mean this
arose during the Enlightenment it was
the idea of your Enlightenment comes
from reason from using your mind and and
and they even though they disagreed on
what reason was how efficacious was it
they had a commitment to reason and to
persuasive argument via reason versus
what well versus Faith obedience to
Authority and then they were
individualists they valued the
individual they thought that the whole
that when we get to political issues it
all has to be from the perspective of
what's good for each and every
individual it was not the kind of divide
people up into groups and which groups
should hold power over others and
everything that's what they were tossing
away and so you can say they're
individualist as against what was
against authoritarians so what they were
against both at at an epistemological
level at a level of knowledge was
obedience to an authority and what they
were against at an ethical and political
level was obedience to Authority it was
enshrining individuals but they had a
real concern with these deeper
philosophic issues and it was only
because they had that deeper philosophy
that they were able to be successful in
politics yeah so objectivists really are
kind of put in the strange situation
that I find myself in as a classical
liberal these days where as you said at
the beginning the left doesn't like
capitalism
and and the right doesn't like
objectivism because irand was against
religion and this is a strange Middle
Ground to be put in is there anyone
politically right now in America that's
operating on these guidelines do you
think on close to objectivist guidelines
um I mean there's definitely people who
I think are really good on sort of
individual issues but like for instance
there's no good label for what I think I
stand for politically I mean I think L
say fair capitalism is a good label but
there's no kind of like organized group
or even semi-organized group uh like I
think libertarian classical liberal at
at most these kind of have you know
vague big tent sorts of meanings today
and unfortunately we don't have much
institutional power right now I think
that's changing a little bit possibly
but at the moment yeah but no I think it
is a minority even the broader
conception of classical liberal is a
minority because you know we talk about
Classical liberalism comes out of the
Enlightenment well there was an
anti-enlightenment there was a movement
and it really solidifi IED um with the
philosopher Emanuel Kant in the late uh
18th century and the kind of the the the
epitome of it today is the social
justice Warriors the postmodernist
philosophers who really I think laid
most of the groundwork for them um but
there was a turn away from the
Enlightenment and it's really affected
virtually everybody today and I think if
you look at Americans they're kind of a
mixture of what einan called a sense of
Life Enlightenment sense of you know
don't put me around I want to live my
life I care about the pursuit of
happiness I'm going to go by Common
Sense not follow some Authority so they
have kind of some remnants of the
Enlightenment but particularly if you
look at the education the schools they
are preaching the most vant anti-reason
anti-individualist Pro authoritarian
sort of ideas I mean I don't have to
tell you and your viewers this yeah um
and so of I think it's no surprise that
people who object to those Trends are in
the minority so in a bizarre way do you
see Trump who certainly is not an
objectivist and it's a little confusing
as to how much he's going to reain back
government or is you know all this stuff
with trade just by putting more tariffs
on that's certainly not uh L aair
economics the way you would probably
want do you think we're at a strange
Crossroads where the social justice
Warriors took a major hit by Trump
winning and yet we don't know what we
have really with Trump so does that do
you view that as sort of an opportunity
to get some of these ideas out there
uh because it's just a a mixed bag
basically at the moment you could say
it's potentially an opportunity but i' I
see it more as if you look at kind of
the historical development of you know
any sort of society um including even
subcultures there's a tendency to bounce
back and forth between two variants of
something bad so for instance nii would
talk about how in his time there was
kind of this this
alternative that we were going to see
between neoism and
authoritarianism uh and now he thought I
mean he saw this as you know being a
result of the death of religion from the
Enlightenment and then the death of the
Enlightenment because they couldn't
Supply a rational code of morality but
but it was that what there's going to be
an oscillation between kind of
Destruction and control and um I think
what we're seeing right now is one kind
of form of that it's that people are fed
up with what what we've been
experiencing the kind of direction that
we've been heading and they're looking
for an alternative but are they looking
rationally or are they looking for
somebody who promises that hey just give
me power and I'll do what's good for you
I'll do what's good for you know what
will make America great again I what
worries me is I see us leaping from um
what people see as kind of the
nistic uh you know statist so-called
left to an authoritarian nationalist
alternative and I think those are no
Alternatives at the end of the day it's
to variants of trying to control other
people's life and money now that doesn't
mean let me just say as a caveat my
point is not that Trump won't do some
things that that I would you know on a
specific issue say yeah I'm glad that
thing would be done right so for example
if he if he lowered taxes you would
probably be for that generally speaking
Al although I'd rather he focus on
reducing regulation which he has talked
about but who knows you know how much
stock you can put in that not a lot um
but yes so there are things that I think
he could do in specific that are good
but what worries me is that I think part
of his appeal was precisely the idea of
people thinking well if we give this guy
power I don't know exactly what he's
going to do but he's going to use it for
people like us that is a very dangerous
route for a country to go down yeah in a
weird way could Trump sort of be an
objectivist gone slightly wrong in that
he it seems like he has some of the
components that you're talking about
selfish in that he's living for himself
and his family and his business and
those things now it doesn't we don't
know what the moral part is right what
the what that piece of it is so that
sort of he's got some of the components
you must like right I would say
emphatically no so I don't think he's
selfish in any way uh einin has an essay
called self uh selfishness with without
a self and what it is it's a she's
looking at this phenomenon of the sort
of people who
basically um they don't think in the way
that we talked about about what
objectively is good for me what
rationally can I justify as in my long
range interest they basically tell
themselves whatever I do is good and uh
because I'm me right and and that's not
selfishness that's really kind of
childishness and it's actually the kind
of psychology that dri somebody like a
Bernie ma off it's that they're driven
purely by emotion and the number one
emotion that they fear feel is a
combination of fear and kind of
self-loathing and that's why here's a
guy who couldn't take criticism and
feels he has to lash out at his enemies
because he has no self-esteem no
self-confidence nobody with genuine
self-esteem which comes from living a
rational productive virtuous life nobody
would be so obsessed with getting the
approval of others and lashing out at
people who give them dis approval so I
mean my view is that as a human being
and I'm my all all indications I've seem
point to there's a really pathetic you
know nothing under that shell of of
boisterousness like that is definitely
not the symbol of what I stand for um
and you know again to put the stress on
it this is certainly not somebody who's
pro- reason he's incoherent trying to
make an argument so at a fundamental
level no um right right I guess I meant
purely at like the idea of the business
level of doing for himself and his
family and business yes but then missing
the components I I mean I understand the
with the thrust of the essay you're
talking about yeah and I mean and even
that it's it's a real question I think
he's a very good marketer um and
certainly you know deserves credit for
uh his his prowess at marketing um but
as a business leader I think you know
there's more an argument that he falls
into the category of what einan or what
today would often be called you know
Cronus uh person who's really good at
playing the political system and getting
special favors irran put it as the
phenomenon of pool pedaling it's that
when you have a government that's not
limited in its powers it has enormous
enormous privileges it can give out and
enormous and then special penalties that
it can give out and then what you get is
you get people who are really good at
playing the game and who rise rather
than through productive achievement they
rise through being able to you know um
rub shoulders with the rub elbows with
the right
[Music]
people